[Music]
one key development that we see
occurring in ursula k le guin's fourth
earth sea novel
is the emergence of
justice or at least the hope that
justice and order are being brought back
to
the lands of earthsea and everything is
taking place
on the island of gant but god could be
viewed as sort of a stand-in
for the rest of earth sea as well now
this is coming about because there's
actually a king again in earthsea which
has not been the case for a very long
time and there's a lot of backstory
going into the earlier
novels particularly the tombs of ottawa
in which we see the ring of ereth ekba
restored and the farthest shore in which
we have the young king
in fact
becoming kingly and
you know we we end with uh the dragon
taking him to rock and this
acknowledgement of him
as a king and then ged the ark mage
going off now why is this so important
because things are so
screwed up and they're not screwed up
just in a well things are falling apart
over here but they're just fine over
here sort of way instead at least at
places like like rogue
there's a lot of problems that are
occurring and
early on
there's this discussion about
gangs and thieves and here's here's the
paragraph what lark had said about gangs
and thieves was not just the complaint
each generation makes that things aren't
what they used to be and the world's
going to the dogs this is a common
dynamic right
in the last several years there had been
a loss
of peace and trust in the towns and
countrysides of gantt
young men behaved like strangers among
their own people abusing hospitality
stealing selling what they stole beggary
was common where it had been rare and
the unsatisfied beggar threatened
violence women did not like to go alone
in the streets and roads nor did they
like that loss of freedom some of the
young women ran off to join the gangs of
thieves and poachers often they came
home within the year sullen bruised and
pregnant
and among village sorcerers and witches
there was rumor of matters of their
profession going amiss charms that had
always cured did not cure
spells of finding found nothing or the
wrong thing love potions drove men into
frenzies not of desire but murderous
jealousy and worse than this they said
people who knew nothing of the art of
magic the laws and limits of it and the
dangers of breaking them were calling
themselves people of power promising
wonders of wealth and health to their
followers
promising even immortality
ivy the witch of gohan's village had
spoken darkly of this weakening of magic
and so had beech the sorcerer of
valmouth and this is what what beech
then says i think a time in which such
things as this occur
must be a time of ruining
the end of an age
how many hundred years since there was a
king in havnor it can't go on so we must
turn to the center again or be lost
island against island man against man
father against child the ring of akba is
restored to the tower in havnor i know
who brought it there ten are
that was the sign surely the sign of a
new age to come but we haven't acted on
it
we have no king
we have no center
we must find our heart our strength
maybe the archmage will act
at l at last but no word of any deed of
the arc mage or any heir to the throne
and hovnor had come and so things went
badly on now this is of course before
the events in the third novel
the you know uh
coming back to to rock of young lebanon
and ged
lebanon is going to become the king but
that hasn't happened yet and so things
are disintegrating things are falling
apart it is a moral disorder it is a
cultural and political disorder it is a
disorder among relationships it is also
a cosmic disorder magic is no longer
working the way that it's supposed to
either it doesn't work or it goes awry
and this is the situation
that we're looking at one of the central
problematics with this is the stronger
preying on the weaker and the
condition of theru's
parents and the other two men that
accompany them
all beggars all scoundrels is kind of an
example of this thero is
terribly abused over the course of her
life not just at one point but the
entire time that she's alive she's raped
she's beaten she's malnourished she's
not being raised in any
way that shows anything to a child and
she's thrown living into a fire to die
there fortunately she doesn't
pharaoh's mother is actually going to
die in this as well abused by the very
same men that abuse therau
so the stronger prey on the weaker
people of power prey on those who don't
have power prime example of this is the
wizard of ray alby aspen who is helping
the lord of ray alby to prey upon his
grandson to take the vital energy from
the boy and give it to the old man
promising immortality and so there's a
question is this the end
or will order be restored a little bit
later
when they're on the ship together
tenar and
the
the
king and several others are talking
and so
she ends up saying there is no archmage
of earthsea but there is a king the king
lebanon
and the mage says in whom our trust and
hope are well founded with a warmth that
became him well the bond and watching
and listening smiled
in these past years tenor said hesitant
there have been many troubles many
miseries
my the little girl such things have been
all too common and i have heard men and
women speak of the waning or the
changing of their power
that one whom the ark mage and my lord
defeated in the dry land that cobb
caused untold harm and ruin we shall be
repairing our art healing our wizards
and our wizardry for a long time yet the
mage said
and then tenor says something else
i wonder if there might be more to be
done than repairing and healing i though
that too of course
but i wonder could it be that
one such as cobb could have such power
because things were already altering and
a change a great change has been taking
place has taken place and it's because
of that change we have a king again in
earth sea
perhaps a king
rather
than an ark mage and so you know maybe
it's a transference to political power
rather than something like priestly
power that's going on the king lebanon
and his subjects are at the center of
this the king is a bringer
of order and indeed of justice he is
part of this process of healing but in a
way it's not always medicine that
everybody wants to take because those
who are preying upon those who are
weaker than them are going to
resist this and
in fact even fight against the king
so what we see
is the king himself has a number of
subjects and the king can directly
intervene as he does when he brings
tenor and pharaoh up on the ship taking
them away from handy who had wanted to
take pharaoh away and punish her abuse
her yet again
there's also the king's men protecting
tenar at least for the moment
from the evil wizard aspen
of rey alby
he is about to cast
a curse
upon her something like a stroking touch
went up her spine her hair lifted on her
head she turned around to see the wizard
reach out his staff towards her in the
dark lightnings gathered rounded his
lips part to speak and she thought in
that moment because get as loud as me
lost his major i thought all men had but
i was wrong
and then a civil voice says well well
what do we have here two of the men from
havnor the king's men had come out onto
the road
from the cherry orchards they looked
from aspen to tennar with bland and
courtly expressions as if regretting the
necessity of preventing a wizard from
laying a curse on a middle-aged widow
but really really it would not do
mistress gohan said the man with the
golden broiden shirt and bowed to her
indicating her status the other the
bright-eyed one saluted her also smiling
mistress gohan is one who like the king
bears her true name openly i think and
unafraid living in gantt she may prefer
that we employ her gantis name but
knowing her deeds i asked to do her
honor for she wore the ring no woman
wore since alpharon he drops to one knee
as if it was the most natural thing in
the world took up tenner's right hand
very lightly and quickly and touched his
forehead to her wrist
as the tenor flutter flustered and
warmed right through there's all kinds
of power
in the world thank you these men in
their courtly way are telling the wizard
hey
back off buddy this is an important
person she is somebody that the king
cares about you better watch it wizard
um there's also a talk at one point
where where gad and tenna are talking
and she says yeah the king's men are
going out um some of them are just you
know these courtiers or warriors and
some of them are actually mages going
around what's what's this about and uh
ged says well you know they're seeking
out wrongdoers maybe they're also
seeking out the people who are wrongly
using magic and by this time aspen has
cast a spell on tenor and she can't
quite remember who it is that they ought
to be going
and looking for there's also a great
discussion about um
what the
um
what what what the the king's uh
commands are
before the month was out the villages of
middle valley had met at the round barn
of sodeva to appoint
their own bailiffs and officers of the
peace and to levy attacks upon
themselves to pay the bailiffs wages
with
such were the king's orders brought to
the mayors and elders of the villages
and readily obeyed now this is very
interesting this shows that
institutions that have been allowed to
fall away to disappear
are now being brought about and it's
coming from on high the command of the
king but he's commanding that
local entities
exercise some autonomy he's delegating
to them and saying
you've got to raise your own taxes so
you can pay for people to protect the
weak against the strong to restore the
order
that's missing
it goes on
there were many sturdy beggars and
thieves on the road as ever and the
villagers and farmers were eager
to have order
and safety
now there's another interesting thing
that happens in this passage
some ugly rumors went around such that
lord henno had formed a council of
scoundrels and was enlisting all the
black guards in the countryside to go
about in gangs breaking the heads of the
king's baileys but most people said
just let them try and went home telling
each other that now an honest man could
sleep a bed at night and when what went
wrong the king was sitting right even
though the taxes were beyond all reason
and they'd all be poor men trying to pay
them so there's this acknowledgement
that it is better to have
some
good authority some order some justice
and if people want to get in the way
then you know instead of just saying
well the mighty do what they want to the
week which people were saying about the
you know uh lord of ray i'll be praying
upon his grandson
instead now they're saying yeah let's
knock the teeth out of these bad guys
the king will do it we'll do it they
they have a restored confidence now this
affects some people differently we find
out of course that um tenor's son
when you know he comes back
why is he back in in the house well
because uh here we go she asked him what
ship are you on still the gull no my
ship broke up the k the crews broke up
king's men took her over why if it
wasn't a pirate ship and he says they
said the captain was running some goods
they wanted and you know a little bit
later she says this guy you know he's
lying he's afraid to go back to the sea
he didn't tell me the truth not all the
truth about his ship he was second mate
i suppose he was involved in carrying
stolen goods second-hand piracy i don't
care gantis sailors are all half pirate
but he lies about it he's you know her
son is not a a good man
and is exactly the sort of person that
the king is going to set straight
we also find out that the king is
appointing
courts of law to be held and the men who
abused
theru
they are going to be held accountable
for what they've done
get of course you know uh nearly kills
one of them and they have the which ivy
take him in
and um
we find out that the the witch is is
saying well he'll live he'll live to
hang why because there are now going to
be
courts of
of law right there are now going to be
ways of punishing and protecting
so she said
she says it's up to the king's courts of
law now that they're meeting again
hanged or set to slave
labor
ged says they must be punished right
and what have they done well we find out
that they've not only horribly abused
thero claire brook tells the story
the four of them had been traipsing and
camping and vagranting about near
kahedon and he said the woman would come
into the village to beg all beat about
and burns and bruises all over they'd
send her in the men would see like that
to beg and she'd go back to them and she
told people if she went back with
nothing they'd beat her more so they
said
why go back. but she
if she didn't they'd come after her she
said see and she'd always go with them
but they finally went too far and beat
her to death and they took and left her
body in the old shambles where there's
still some of the stink left you know
maybe thinking that was hiding what
they'd done and they came away then down
here just last night so they were trying
to
they've already committed a murder they
tried to murder theroux after horribly
abusing her they were coming back to
finish the job and probably to also kill
tenor these are the sort of people
that the court of law is going to impose
hanging or being condemned to the
slavery of the the gallows doesn't sound
like something you know good but
it is good within the grand scheme
because it is restoring justice it is
restoring order and we see that one of
the key thematics of this is what does
it mean to actually
do these things it is to keep the
stronger
from preying upon the weak
and so the king
is absolutely central to this but he
can't do it alone he has to
have others come along with him his
subjects his servants his delegates he
has to produce a kind of consensus that
this is better than how things have been
going
you